police in North Carolina released
dramatic video of a deadly encounter
with a kidnapping suspect this happened
last month in Raleigh the video shows
the armed suspect firing at police as he
runs from a vehicle into the woods
Kenneth Craig is here with the details
kind of good morning good morning to you
Dana police released multiple angles of
the incident but perhaps the easiest way
to see exactly what happened in the
suspects final moments would have been
with the body camera on the officer at
the center of this case but it wasn't on
the dash cam footage begins at the tail
end of a high-speed car chase involving
the kidnapping suspect 23 year old hugo
cortez ramirez after his vehicle was
disabled by police cortez ramirez jumps
out of the driver's side and Sprint's
into nearby woods wielding a handgun in
his right hand at least four muzzle
flashes can be seen as cortez ramirez
exchanges fire with police Raleigh
Police Sergeant RL Warner can be seen
firing back
body cameras from other officers showed
deputies take cover near the suspects
vehicle they were told the kidnapping
victim was still inside the suspect
fires one more shot before more deputies
arrive and rescue the victim from the
vehicle the manhunt for Cortez Ramirez
continued into the daylight hours police
say they later found Cortez ramirez's
body in the woods with a pistol in his
hand the officer at the center of that
case sergeant Warner was wearing his
body camera as all of that unfolded but
police say the battery had died before
it happened he's currently on
administrative duty and the state is
investigating as for that victim victim
apparently physically okay obviously a
lot of emotional scars okay Kenneth
thank you very much